xmin actress Vaughn Bingbing is back in
the public eye after mysteriously
disappearing three months ago the
superstar from China resurfaced on
social media yesterday after Chinese
Chinese government officials publicly
accused her of tax evasion now she is
best known here in America for her role
in x-men Days of Future past
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is here with what the
actress is now telling her supporters
vlad can't wait to hear good morning
good morning in the US this would have
been like Julia Roberts or Jennifer
Lawrence suddenly vanishing from public
view but after months of speculation
China's most famous actress has finally
reappeared with facing millions of
dollars in tax fines she's a fixture on
the red carpet
the face of many international luxury
brands and one of China's most
recognizable and highest-paid actresses
today and three months ago she simply
disappeared but on Wednesday China's
official news agency announced that 37
year-old Phan Bing Bing had been charged
with tax evasion and has been ordered to
pay nearly 130 million dollars in
overdue taxes and fines in her first
social media post in nearly four months
Vaughn apologized to the public writing
I feel shamed and guilty for what I have
done adding she would quote try my best
to overcome all difficulties and raise
funds to pay back taxes and fines it
sent a shockwave through China when she
disappeared Robert Kane is a producer
who writes about China's film industry
the government is sending a very strong
message to everyone that no one is above
this we didn't deal with celebrities
before we've never taken them into a
custody like this but now you know the
rules are different and so watch out
some Chinese actors may have what are
called yin-yang contracts for each film
where one contract shows that actors
real earnings while another contract
lists a lower figure that lower figure
is then reported to tax officials
allowing the actor to evade taxes last
year Forbes reported fun was worth an
estimated 43 million dollars in 2016 she
ranked as the fifth highest paid actress
in the world right behind Jennifer
Aniston this summer China's government
imposed a cap on actors pay at 70% of
the total pay to all the actors in a
film hotel
celebrities like Jackie Chan and film
studios are required by the Chinese
government to promote core socialist
values
despite bonds well-documented charity
work
Caine says it's unclear whether the
actress will bounce back that may well
be that her career is over as an
international star but it's hard to say
sometimes people just disappear for good
in China Fon is expected to appear in
the upcoming Bruce Willis film air
strike while her exact whereabouts
remain unknown
she paid tribute to the Chinese state on
social media writing without the good
policies of the Communist Party and the
state without the love of the people
there is
no fun being being I love how you put it
in perspective in the beginning
comparing her to Julia Roberts and
Jennifer Lawrence noir and I was just
not at least puts it in perspective this
like look at each other shouldn't there
be some sort of healthy skepticism about
this given that statement I mean I'm
seeing the government in that way right
praising the government saying her
identity doesn't exist without the
government I mean if you want chills
yeah that'll give it to you and the fact
that is that you know there are reports
that because we still don't actually
know where she was but they're calling
it a resort facility so there you go
Hausa well back to my point I said thank
you Miss gay perspective about how big
she is
I don't know I wait to see her income -
I brought - I've been following this
story because she's been missing for so
long three months yeah that's a long
time thank you thank you very
fascinating